[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
family hurt oh my god family
right now artists Rovin people causing a
multi-chain incident
somebody might be mad folks somebody
might
[Applause]
really badly injured on the ground
and a car smashed into all the cars and
his family out of there was completely
tinted up completely fix it up oh my god
so somebody new tomorrow we condemn in
the strongest possible terms this
egregious display of hatred bigotry and
violence on many sites on many sites
please people call the manga 1 we need
multiple ambulances I don't know what
the street is
a lot of people article minutes
[Applause]